hundreds of thousands of federal workers
are living without pay during the
shutdown Julie Clark for instance is a
park ranger in Northern California but
her side business is cleaning windows
it's now her only source of income she
says she's worried about defaulting on
her student loans
Latika parrot of the Bureau of Land
Management she's a single mom who was
down to her last $800 they both watched
the President's speech with Carter Evans
and say they did not get the message
they were hoping for yeah I was hoping I
was like oh they're gonna put us back to
work tomorrow that's what I was hoping
to hear to be I mean maybe I'm living in
a dream world but it seems even more
polarized and I could have imagined it's
gotten worse I think so yeah we all have
to make compromises with each other
throughout our daily lives with our boss
our partner it seems like the government
it should be a great example of that and
they just don't seem to come together
right now
do you feel like you're stuck in the
middle of this do you feel like you're
being used yeah definitely I feel like a
pawn in a game that I did I don't agree
with but yeah I definitely feel stuck
and there's just there's absolutely
nothing I can do about it I'm pretty
resilient but I do not like being in
this position and I feel almost like I'm
being punished for something I didn't do
in California an Air Force veteran was
raped murdered I'm beaten to death with
a hammer he told some pretty awful
stories agreed you can see where he's
coming from yes I just don't feel like
to hold the country hostage I don't buy
it that that has to happen you know he
has to hold the country hostage to get
this at your expense at my expense yeah
at all of our expenses all the single
palms that are struggling and going oh
my god what am I gonna do it seems like
no people have dug their heels in and
what I hope is that they can both come
together and have a valuable compromise
and that includes us going back to work
what a fascinating discussion hearing
that Carter Evans speaking with federal
workers in Arcadia California